what I will say about Madonna the gays
are gonna kill me
I saw her one time and it wasn't great
everyone's New York confessions
confessions on the dance floor it wasn't
it was in the DNA oh that's gone yeah
that was the whole dance album right we
know confessions was the dance okay so
the DNA was like in 2012 I think I was
on MDMA when I went to me what that girl
is okay I paid a lot of money for those
tickets we were at Madison Square Garden
somewhere out in Jersey girl yeah I was
way up there in the rafters and I was
just like yeah yeah I'll wait so I'll
wait till they're the farewell Vegas
tour where she finally does all the
things that people want to hear right
well age why she's she's getting there
yeah but you know she keeps it together
she keeps it together she does she does
all right let's uh let's talk a little
bit about I've heard Candice talk about
how most black people actually are
conservative but they sort of don't know
it or they can't accept it because of
the way the media has treated black
people that the default position is you
must be a Democrat you sense that um I
sense that and to get into that you
really have to understand how deeply
entrenched this idea that black people
have to be Democrat says and and I said
this a little bit on the Vice thing that
I did
we have black celebrities entertainers
ballplayers athletes from the top of the
charts to the inste thought with 10,000
followers these are all people that are
pushing leftists you know they're
pushing leftist tactics and black people
we more so than I think other races we
look for representation and media and we
look for representation in pop culture
and these are our heroes these are the
people that we want to be like and
that's one of the reasons why this idea
that we have to be on the left is so
firmly entrenched so what why do you
think that is looking for it sort of
elsewhere do you think that has
something to do with the the black
family and some of the stuff that Larry
elder would talk about it has everything
to do with Larry elders talking about
Larry elder will tell you and I'm pretty
sure he did that be number one
kick the [ __ ] out of me yeah that's what
woke me up
but Larry elder will tell you that the
number one problem in the the black
community is black bobynin lessness
right that we don't have men in the
homes and so when there's not a man in
the home when there's not a man to raise
that young man in the home they look to
athletes ballplayers the the Colin
Kaepernick's whoever and so when Colin
Kaepernick just to give an example if
some kids hero right and he sees Colin
Kaepernick taking a knee for black lives
matter and that's where he's getting his
politics from because that kid doesn't
know who I am that kid certainly doesn't
know who larry elder is and the fact
that that kid is not gonna know who
larry elder is is a shame you know what
i mean and so that's the message that we
get even though black people do tend to
be a little bit more conservative just
in terms of if you for example said that
black people need fathers in the home
and we need to stop having kids out of
wedlock and we need to start doing all
of these things that will elevate
ourselves you're a racist obvious or
resist
i would say i would say everyone
regardless of race right should have
those things defense to their ability
not to say can't happen otherwise you
just said you were you were raised by
your mother i want do turned out pretty
good i worse there were those outlier
cases yeah but at the same time i was i
went to military for five years and so
the military taught me the military gave
me a male influence multiple male
influences the military taught me how to
be a man the military taught me
discipline the military taught me
courage the military taught me
self-control the military taught me
reliance all of the things that a father
is supposed to teach you and so now me
as a as a gay black man saying these
things you know if you're a white person
you know your white supremacist your
whatever but i'll i'm sorry about that
you know yeah i'm the [ __ ] I'm the Uncle
Tom I'm whatever and there is this very
huge movement of like very far left gay
black men who it seems like they have
these large online platforms and it
seems like their entire goal in life is
to just tear down straight black men or
tear down the idea of masculinity or
tear down the idea that our boys need
men in the homes to teach them how to be
men
so I want to tear that down and when I
look at their platforms and I look at
the things that they say and sometimes
they come after me and I ignore it
because none of those people are my
enemy that there is nobody that is out
there that's a public figure that looks
like me that is not my enemy
that is my these people are not my enemy
but when I look at the platform that
they have I say you have so many people
listening to you why are you always
preaching divisive nough sin hatred why
are you trying to tear down black men we
should be lifting each other up we
should be empowering each other because
you know our community needs it yeah
well it seems to me that mostly and it's
not just with say those black men but
anyone that buys in to the far-left
ideology they want conformity yeah and
they there is some sort of as I say all
the time Peter bagozzi who's been on the
show many times calls this postmodern
ideology a secular religion mm-hmm and
they don't want apostate and they
especially don't want apostates that
look like you that's crazy I've never
I've never really heard that I mean I've
talked about that idea and some of my
lectures but I've never heard it say
quite like that because this is my thing
and and one of the best things that
happened for me over the past year is
that I found religion and I found God
because I will tell you and you probably
know they're in and I don't know I don't
know what your religion is yeah but for
me there's a lot of people that are
running after Twitter followers and fans
and Instagram followers and fame and
money and all this other stuff and not
there's not an amount of Twitter
followers or fame or any of that stuff
that is gonna fill that hole that you're
looking to fill and Twitter followers
don't fill the existential void the
black hole of existence yeah I filled by
Instagram life is naughty and you've got
like 10 times my following and when when
things started taking off a little bit
last year like when when my life started
getting bigger and in some other ways I
had to make things smaller hmm and so I
made my circle smaller and I try to get
closer with my husband and my best
friends but I also found God and it is
really not religious before were you not
were you were you specifically not a
believer before no not at not at all I
was raised in the church African
Methodist Episcopal yeah
so the AME Church like I was there and
when you're young and black in the
church church is a full like an all-day
event I'm there at 10:00 a.m. for Sunday
school and then you do the service and
then it's 2:30 dinner you like you're
not out of there till after dark but I
think that in my first 11 years in the
city when I was kind of doing some of
the Don't Ask Don't Tell activism and
trying to find my path I was looking for
fulfillment and all of those things that
I told you before and when I started
getting those things I realized that not
that it wasn't enough but there needs to
be something else to ground me and one
of the biggest things that the the super
far left tells young gay people is that
God is your enemy and Christians are
your enemy and Evangelic Oh Christian
'he's want to put you in conversion him
and just all of this crazy stuff to
separate them from religion so that this
far-left ideology becomes their religion
and i I say that you know God is a gift
in my life right now and I say that and
and I'm not embarrassed by that anymore
and I don't feel like that's something
that I should be ashamed to talk about
even as a gay man somebody described me
on on Twitter when I think it's funny
and they said former military leftists
turn right-wing bible-thumping Trump
hard and I thought that a lot of words I
thought was hysterical yeah I show that
to my husband we both cackle I don't
hear you bible-thumping no I mean I'm
not there maybe a trump tarted oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah right-wing Trump tart I
don't Bible thump I just I talked that I
talk about religion in my life and how
its grounded me and how it's become just
a really powerful guiding force yeah and
it it is fulfilling and it is grounding
in a way that let me tell you something
as a young gay man like but all the sex
all the partying all that stuff like I
did it all and there's there's nothing
in that and for me it is is becoming
grounded and religion and God yeah do
you think a lot of gay people have like
an extra struggle when it comes to sort
of the existential questions because I
know I definitely did like that
you are something that society tells you
at least you know how old are you huh
how old you am I allowed to ask how old
you are I just get to the one question
that no one course you can I'm in my
thirties day you're in your 30s Wow Wow
yeah yeah all right so that's how it is
well I as an elder I am 42 years okay so
you know when I was in sa high school in
college you know this way before he gave
marriage yeah you know during Don't Ask
Don't Tell and I never really saw sort
of a functional future it's not that I
saw a dysfunctional future I just saw no
future I was just like I'm now and I'm
just gonna keep living now yeah
something like that yeah
but I do think for a lot of gay people
that causes like this weird belief
schism yeah something like that so it's
interesting to hear that just in the
last year yeah you've come back to some
of this stuff and I think a lot of
people have by the way I think they are
in and I want them to and it's like so
we we Toby I guess I don't wanna say
right-wing there's any more because I
guess I'm a right-wing or no but they
always say that you know you can't call
gay a lifestyle because it's my sexual
orientation aside life so but there are
elements of it that are very lifestyle
oriented the the party lifestyle the
circuit party culture the gay culture
like all of that other stuff I don't
like any of it yeah I like the Golden
Girls
who doesn't like to go yes I know that's
like gay for me you know I mean I
watched three hours the Golden Girls on
a Sunday morning I'm very happy but the
cool thing right now is that people like
you and people like me can reach these
young people and they can see something
that is outside of all of that messiness
and I come to it it's not somebody that
judges it but if somebody that did it
all now I never did drugs that was never
I was never a druggie
I don't even like smoking weed they say
that people that are that are a little
neurotic and I'm a little neurotic they
say weed doesn't go well with us and it
doesn't go well with me yes I never did
the drugs you haven't found the right in
to go but I get it you're a conservative
now it's - yeah yeah no it's not even
that because something it is funny funny
I'm like to the right of some people on
marijuana legalization but that's a
whole nother issue we could we can go
there but yeah good but I did all the
partying I did all the circuit parties
i'ma travel than kissing
I'm having like this it's like I did all
that and I fundamentally know that
there's nothing there and I think that
the problem with reaching these kids
right now is that I am like it feels
lonely because it really does feel like
I'm one of maybe three or four people
that like have these large platforms and
obviously you as well but they see
people that are like you know they see
the drag queens and the Hollywood
celebrities and all that other stuff I
just really want these kids to see that
they can have a more grounded life and
not that I'm trying to be anybody's role
model in a way because I'm like my thing
is I did all the mess so you don't have
to yeah I feel very even though I didn't
do the me and I did do my own mess in a
way like and I did I did do the drugs
and I did do all that but I wasn't
really into the scene let's say but I do
feel that - I'm not trying to be
anyone's role model and all a hundred
you were saying not for failure yeah and
I I lived through if anything I would
say I lived through [ __ ] to get to where
I am so that hopefully the next that
that gay kid that's 18 doesn't have to
do it you know yeah right because
everyone's got [ __ ] well yeah yeah all
right and the people that came before me
lived through far more than that so yeah
but there's an interesting parallel here
with the way Hollywood treats all of
this because you mentioned something
about just a moment ago you mentioned
how that black culture puts more
emphasis on Hollywood and these figures
and everything I was thinking like even
just in the Oscars last year that black
pant there yeah it was nominated for an
Oscar now I've seen every so I so I
think we're gonna have a little
difference here I I've seen every Marvel
movie I just saw endgame a couple days
ago yeah I was gonna make me go see that
this week yeah yeah I don't want to say
anything right now but but I've seen
every one of the movies I love superhero
movies out of Star Wars a love all that
stuff Black Knight there was a very
average movie there was in my opinion
there was nothing racist yes it was a
shame for shame racist what guess what
Larry I love you said it too yeah but
he's a self-hating black guy yeah I just
can't wait here but my point is but it
was if within the scheme of superhero
movies yeah none of them
nominated for anything yeah and that's
fine that it was very average in my
opinion it was just a very average movie
and it got nominated for all these
things and I saw the media was like ah
see Black Panther got it like it was
some major win yeah that would somehow
make people more equal or feel later or
now we can look at the numbers and go
this many black films this and this many
white balances and I was like it just
seems to me that the aim yes so off yeah
where you should go for the prize and
real prize
no and I agree with you on that personal
I love black panther I really do like
I'm a huge fan
perfectly fine but you had an Oscar
award-winning I think dominated but I
think that you make a really good point
in minority communities and specifically
the two groups that I'm a part of blacks
in gay people we always look for
representation in the media as some sort
of barometer of progress and that's a
trap it's a huge it's a big tribal
Chinese people do it yeah because
they're focused on making money and when
I attend and I'm all about it and when I
go give these lectures and I tell people
that the biggest way for any group of
people to achieve any kind of power is
financially it is not through the Oscar
nominations and that stuff is great and
it's amazing but it's it's it's kind of
like these are these are false idols
because Black Panther is is great for
visual representation and it's great
that all those people on the stage and I
personally think this amazing movie yeah
but what that does for the young black
kid that's struggling in the high school
that I went to right now not much not
much right yeah and we do it as as gays
and lesbians as well if you know if
somebody comes out and look at the look
at the Buddha judge thing right now yeah
yeah yeah look at how people and this is
somebody that is I mean I'm not a Buddha
judge hater at all but I it seems to me
you know I see the game I see what's
going on and I see the way that he
picked the fight with pence to
ingratiate himself to the far left that
there's it like I get it yeah I see it
but just the idea that any power comes
from media
representation it's it's false hope and
it also separates the people from what
should be the end goal because I think
that empowerment for any of our
communities only comes through
entrepreneurship look at this look at
that that is your name on that sign
you're an entrepreneur and if somebody
had given me the message about
entrepreneurship when I was 17 18 19 20
God knows where I'd be by now and one of
the biggest things that I've gotten out
of out of become a conservative and kind
of moving over to the right is the fact
that entrepreneurship and capitalism is
not a bad thing and my both of our
communities need more of it but
especially my black community we need
more entrepreneurship we need more job
creators we need to stop looking for
representation in the media to to to
elevate ourselves or to make us feel
good about ourselves so when you see
then the Democrats so just in the last
couple weeks there's now this debate
suddenly about reparations and I saw the
video of senator Elizabeth Warren
talking about reparations she's gonna
Commission a panel about reparations and
my first thought the first thing that
just popped into my head as I was
watching it was holy [ __ ] Candace did it
you know what I mean like whatever
anyone thinks - Candace she created
enough of a crack in that layer that
that caused black people to either be
completely afraid of saying they're
conservatives or yeah just say that
they're not democrat yeah yeah that now
the Democrats are like oh [ __ ] what do
we got left here's money could you take
somewhere that's money in the words of
the great Candace Owens beer in handouts
is what they have to offer black people
the cycle and it is no mistake first of
all that Donald Trump got more
african-american votes from the two
previous Republican nominees combined
that is just a fact and it is no mistake
that you know what you know people say a
lot about the blacks at movement and
they say it's not real it's not that and
what I tell people is that you're going
to see Republicans make a bigger play
for the black vote then you have ever
seen before I think in the history of
this country and it's not going to come
through fear and handouts
it's gonna come from talking to the
people that are the real job creators
and the real entrepreneurs and saying
that these policies will help you create
and the fact that reparations is even a
conversation right now among the
Democrats means that they're scared I I
just did a video for for turning-point
about reparations and and not to spoil
any of that but none other than Bayard
Rustin who is one of the architects of
the march on Washington a huge civil
rights leader and who by the way was
black and gay in the 60s they
interviewed Bayard Rustin about
reparations in 1969 and he said it's he
said this idea is ridiculous and the
quote is something like if my
great-great grandfather you know picked
cotton then reparations are owed to him
but he's dead and nobody owes me
anything yeah but this is how they're
gonna try to buy the black vote it's
also just a crazy way of dividing us yes
each other I was at a cousin's wedding
on my husband's side this past weekend
and was with a young guy who's 21 22 and
he was telling me about how low kid is
in college now this is a kid who grew up
his mother died when he was very young
he grew up he had no money bunch of
different homes mm-hmm all sorts of
crazy history in the family and it's
like the idea that this kid has
privilege because he's white and we're
gonna take from him but not see in
essence that's what he was like and it
wasn't specifically about reparations
but just this idea that this kid is
somehow guilty
yeah we're somehow privileged just
because of the skin color having nothing
to do with everything he's lived through
but that's what they're pushing on
everybody I mean you know that's what
they're pushing and and there's not a
lot of pushback to that idea and I just
feel that there's a correction going on
right now and there's a correction
because you're seeing a lot more
conservatives that are younger and
browner and whatever and there's a
really different movement right now and
the the leftist it's like I call it the
intersectionality cult the
intersectionality cult will eat itself
because there's all these things that
you cannot say on the left right now and
there's somebody who am NOT gonna name
but this is this person is it has a
platform as
a feminist right and this is male
feminist and I'm like great you know do
what you got to do but don't call me
transphobic for defending women's sports
or women's spaces or or lesbians who are
now who now feel pressured into having
relationships with transgender women
yeah when when you call yourself a
feminist and you're not standing up for
for lesbians and I standing up for women
in that way I you know you call me
whatever you want to call me but I'm
always going to to stand up for for
lesbians to stand up for women in that
way but like I said the
intersectionality coat they're things
that they can't say they're things that
they can't say about radical Islam you
know when when they run into a gay bar
and kill 49 of us and then they can't
say that you got Jonathan Capehart
running around talking about oh this guy
was a closeted gay and this guy was this
and this guy was that and I'm like that
is completely ridiculous and not true
and we know that that's not true now but
the intersectionality coat will eat
itself because there there it it is
becoming to the point where there are
too many things that they can't say so
people like you and I have to say the
things that they can't say it is that
doubly tough then for you as a gay black
man because the culture if we're talking
about black culture and gay culture you
have so much humor richness their
political incorrect yeah yeah all of
these things so for someone like you to
be fed these these ideas you've
obviously rejected that yeah but to be
fed these ideas that would stop you from
joking the way you want a joke or saying
something politically incorrect rest of
it it's like like I remember go when I
would go to gay bars and there would be
like a drag queen now I saw again I was
never into it I thought drag queens were
all bad comics like they all struck me
as just hot comics that being said they
would say a ton of politically incorrect
[ __ ] they would mock gay people they I
mean they would mock everybody that was
the point yeah where now it's like I
don't know I don't know what's going on
in the the drag queen world these days
but it's like I'm guessing it's gotten
pretty bad because they're probably
really afraid yeah to be irreverent I
mean I think that right now I mean I
love drag RuPaul's Drag Race I'm all
about it you know my my husband and I
are big fans when I voted for the in the
last lecture a voting for Gary Johnson
but I used to live in West Hollywood so
I had to go
were there to vote yeah I'm standing
behind RuPaul at the voters Wow
not in drag and you want to talk about
like and you want to talk about how
crazy the left is they went out let's
just about RuPaul let's talk about the
crazy blue chase this is the point
Razi's on the LGBTQ left coming after
RuPaul like the forgive me for being gay
mother you come from mother yeah you say
that RuPaul is transphobic or she
doesn't represent gays a winner
well what was it that she said about a
year and a half ago there's a buddy a
year and a half ago like RuPaul did an
interview where she says she doesn't
Paul he because RuPaul's a man RuPaul
said he doesn't believe in
transgender women and dry because drag
is supposed to be a male's elevated and
comedic idea of what a woman is and so
they came after RuPaul for that they
came after there was a segment on drag
race called [ __ ] girl you got shemail
you know what I mean and so they kid the
blue checks came after RuPaul for that
and so it's really funny when I look at
the RuPaul situation and we'll look at
somebody who was done more for for LGBT
culture then maybe anybody walking on
this earth right now and the fact that
people are attacking him after
everything that he's done tells me that
these people are insane tells me that
there's not enough and if there's one
thing that that I wouldn't you I don't
know if this is a critique because I
love RuPaul and by all accounts I hear
people say that rue is amazing it's that
like we'll kind of bended bended the
knee a little bit
I know he apologized bended the knee a
little bit to people coming for him and
I want to get to a point where we are
not bending the knee to the mob anymore
yeah they came after Ellen DeGeneres
what lesbian on this planet has done
more for frickin gay and lesbian
visibility and an Ellen DeGeneres you
know it came after Ellen just because
she sat down with Kevin Hart Kevin Hart
right a Bheema conversational Kevin Hart
and they came for Ellen and so this is
what I say if they're coming for RuPaul
and Ellen DeGeneres they'll come for you
and me so die so I will never
in the knee I was we were supposed to
have an an LGBTQ conservative panel at
the LGBT Center in New York City and
when you know people found out about it
we've got excommunicated from the center
because we were all racist and all quiet
and transphobic and all of that other
stuff and so I will never apologize for
things that I say I don't try to offend
people but you're certainly not going to
control my tongue and I'm not gonna Bend
the need of these people and I'm really
glad that Ellen didn't and I hope RuPaul
never does again because these are two
people that have done more for this
community than anybody in the planet
certainly not some blue checkmark that
writes for some blog right but we create
this reverse or this perverse I should
say incentive structure where it's like
there's a lot of value for those blue
checkers we go after them because it's
like oh you can wound one of the heroes
yeah even if they were the ones that
paved the road for you yeah Wow if you
can build your castle on their blood
yeah you know the cart cardi B says
they'd do anything for clout coach a so
that's how they're doing and the the
fundamental critique that I have with
with a lot of these people that the
cloud chasers is that the platform's are
always built on destruction it's
canceled culture so everything is always
built on if I build a platform of let's
say like a hundred thousand two hundred
thousand three hundred thousand and my
platform is completely built on tearing
people down like I'm gonna go up to Dave
Rubin because he's got ten times my
following and he said something I don't
like so maybe I'll get some attention
for for tearing him down yeah you know
what I mean so if your platform is built
on that then you always have to look for
new things to be offended by new people
to destroy new cloud to chase and I
don't think that it goes anywhere yeah
you know well it's also sad right it's
like it's deeply sappy and I see this
with this crew going after me all the
time and I just ignore it but it's like
the idea that you're waking up in the
morning and going what did Rubin say
today so I can get some clicks it's like
man there's so many things going on in
the world yeah it's like I'm not perfect
and I've made mistakes in this very room
yeah this show but it's like if you're
waking up going this is the guy we got
to go after I thought about you that it
says about me it doesn't
feel sorry I just I feel sorry for their
life because I just there's nowhere to
go from that and I would like to use
these opportunities that I'm getting
right now to I want to engage people but
I also want to empower people I want to
empower my people as much crap as
Candice owns gets and man she gets the
level that I could even dream of
she is a true believer
she is really out here trying to empower
people she is really out here trying to
wake people up and I am I saw a brené
Brown special I think her name is renee
brown on on Netflix so she says
apparently enormous Lea huge
motivational speaker but never heard of
um so she just got promoted to me on
Netflix so I decided to watch a little
bit of V M special and she said that and
I think she I think this is a Theodore
Roosevelt quote she said that don't
worry about critiques that come from
people who are not in the field who are
not in the battle who are not putting
themselves out there in some way in
trying to affect change in some way and
now that I've saw I've seen that that's
how I try to live my life because you
can't take all these critiques there's a
point where you can get 90% of love from
people and will focus on their sin I
hate yeah I was really doing stand-up I
always remember I could be killing like
300 people laughing exactly
if there's one guy looking at his phone
it's like that's the guy I'm looking at
yeah yeah that was a sweep of my lecture
last oh did you call him out I did I
didn't call him out directly but I was
like giving my speech or I was like you
know in and I think that everybody needs
to have conversations even that guy did
he wake up he did he did it I'm sorry we
didn't do more of this earlier but tell
me a little bit just about your service
having nothing to do with with all yeah
just you know my service in general I I
think that when I look back at the
military service what I regret is that
you know people come up to you when
you're veteran and they thanked you for
your service and like people call me a
hero and all that other stuff and I'm
always uneasy by that because I didn't
do anything particularly heroic
was a young kid just just trying to make
it from one day to the next I mean I was
doing things that I believed in but when
I look at some of these kids that are
serving right now and they're the same
age I was you know 19 20 21 years old
it's so much for a young person to take
on but for me when I look back at it and
it just it you know I lost weight and it
gave me discipline and it gave me kind
of that that strong male influence that
was missing in my life and when I talk
about my service it's not so much the
day-to-day of what I did because it was
really you know I did one tour in Kuwait
I did want to learn a rock right after
the invasion you connect those dots you
can get to that age question that yes
it's okay yeah but when I look back to
that we were just I was just trying to
do the best that I could and everybody
that I served with we were just trying
to do our best and the people that are
serving the military they are heroes
from like from the guy who captured
Osama bin Laden and Indies these great
men that you see these books from and
all that stuff but just the people that
they give up three four five sometimes
20 and 25 years of their life to be of
service in some way like there is a very
heroic element to that and I think that
with me and my service I talk about it a
lot and I talk about loving America
because it has given me so much just
that service has just put me onto a path
that just sitting here with you right
now and coming back from being with
Candis and going to events in the white
house like what what more black kid from
Akron Ohio could could see that vision
for himself and the military put me on
the path to doing all of these things so
I don't look at myself as heroic but I
look at all the people that are serving
now as heroic it's to me it's it's very
strange I feel like I'm not giving you
an answer but no no it's very hard to
reconcile Who I am now with who I was
then and to see that as anything other
than a scared kid doing the best he
could if that makes sense
it does make sense yeah and that feels
like a nice ending yeah how do you feel
about that I think that's a great
very I don't know what I'm doing later
but there would be something if we just
showed up at the Abbey and West Holly
could we find some other band at
deplorable oh my god reeks and we should
we should make it happen we should we
should make the could the conservative
gay meet up or something like that I
should make a happen classical liberal
oh that's right classical liberal come
on in for more on Rob follow them on
Twitter at Rob Smith online
[Music]